quand les stars abuse des passe droits
donc c'était le scandale cette semaine
aux états unis
plusieurs actrices hollywoodiennes sont
accusés d'avoir versé des pots de vin
afin de faire entrer leurs enfants dans
des prés ce tissu prestigieuse
université on sait que là-bas ça coûte
une fortune
si vous n'avez pas une bourse d pas
droit qui passe très mal donc
évidemment ça a été révélée un peu parlé
mediapart locaux là bas donc est-ce
qu'il faut être choqué par un tel
comportement grosso modo le piston
choquait pas choquer regardez on en
parle après les universités argent
corruption et privilèges de quoi faire
trembler hollywood
felicity huffman de la série desperate
housewives et femme de l'acteur où il ya
messi aurait versé 15 mille dollars pour
que les résultats des examens de leur
fille soit falsifiés pour intégrer une
université prestigieuse et lori loughlin
de la série la fête à la maison
aurait-elle versé 500 mille dollars de
pots-de-vin pour que ses filles soit
admise à la saos university of
california je pense que c'est vraiment
injuste pour le reste d'entre nous qui
devons travailler très dur et ce n'est
pas juste que ces réacteurs et pdg
puisse faire ça pendant que nos autres
nous devons respecter les règles du jeu
en plus le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que olivia jane la fille de laurie n'est
pas vraiment discrète avec un million
d'abonnés sur instagram elle passe son
temps à faire des vidéos de décérébrés
à sa décharge le vide intersidéral ça a
l'air d'être une histoire de famille
la liste des stars qui pussent de leur
célébrité est longue comme le bras
johnny téléphoné à nicolas sarkozy alors
président en pleine nuit pour régler de
petits problèmes fiscaux
christian clavier elle faisait
surveiller sa maison en corse aux frais
des contribuables
et que dire de neymar que les fans
croyait en arrêt maladie et qu'on a
retrouvés au carnaval de rio
ce piston trafic d'influencé amitiés
politiques en tous genres face aux stars
qui abusent de passe droit vous êtes
choqués ou va choquer
voilà choqué pas choqué de ces stars qui
abusent de passe-droit vous l'avez vu un
pion peut même aller un peu plus loin
même sur des stars françaises tous à
élargir un petit peu le double débat
pardon choqué évidemment notre catéchèse
habituel monsieur gentil du monde
guillaume tu as compris le sujet oui
j'ai compris j'en suis choqué am
évidemment je suis très choquée pourquoi
jusque là mais grâce que toi je suis
choquée parce que je suis désolé mais on
est en démocratie
oui voilà et que parce qu'on est un peu
célèbre d'abord quand on a un
passe-droit c'est en échange de quelque
chose généralement ouais donc de largeur
là c'est de l'argent
ouais mais je suis choqué que les gens
voient ce dire parce que je suis un peu
connu je vais demander à à payer moins
d'impôts et alors aujourd'hui en plus
les stars sont en train d' exemple
johnny hallyday les stars sont en train
de vouloir des passe droits parce que ça
leur assure une notoriété vis-à-vis des
autres parce qu'elle est n pouvoir le
dire il ya beaucoup de stars notamment
qui demande aujourd'hui à avoir des
protection policière en disant vous
comprenez je suis tellement de grandes
stars c'est un peu un signe extérieur de
richesse comme aurait il fallu une rolex
et donc j'en connais beaucoup je ne
donnerai pas le nom de star française
qui disent je veux une protection
il y en a même qui demanda à parce
qu'ils sont extrêmement connue à à ce
que leurs proches
les gens qui les gardent et des armes
mais j'en suis et d'où elle est un petit
peu du sujet qui fait que je veux savoir
c'est est ce que le piston grosso modo
c'est très jaloux shox et je suis désolé
c'est alors la géorgie on verra mieux
qu'une farce aimons ça me choque oui
mais j'ai compris que mon chéri pas
choquer sébastien je rappelle que l'on
n'a pas les 15 minutes ça ça peut monter
jusqu'à 500 mille dollars dm1 millions
ses montées oui dans les plus grands
comptes dans les plus grandes
universités ou quand vous en sortez vous
êtes avocat pas tout de suite vous avez
des parts incroyable et rentre dans
l'université
vu le qi d'huitre d'une des deux filles
je suis pas sûr qu'elles en sortent mais
avec un chèque 30 avec al cheikh du sort
avec un sale alors il va falloir payer
beaucoup peut se révèle franchement
c'était précieux qu'est vous non je suis
pas choqué des passe-droits la
corruption c'est autre chose mais les
passe-droits moi qui suis toujours
derrière les stars je vois comment ça se
passe
et souvent ils ont rien à demander un il
arrive dans un restaurant ya pas de
place on leur donne les arrête dans un
avion on les surclasse il en profite
vous devez connaître et à mathieu
moi c'est pas vrai oui oui je suis
d'accord mais ça se met il y en a deux
alors il y en a qui le demande y en a
trop qu'ils aient souvent les petits
parce que ceux des mecs comme johnny
quand ils arrivent quelque part il a il
a besoin de rien demander si a pas de
passe dans le restaurant lui donne dans
l'avion c'est pareil et c'est donc ça
c'est pas droits dus à la célébrité dans
ce cas là on est dans de la corruption
où il ya d'ailleurs que sur les 40 50
personnes que deux stars qui donc on est
dans un truc un peu différent mais les
passe-droits suis pas choqué d'accord
choqué alors pas choquer pas choqué
aussi à socke et mathieu pourquoi oui je
suis choquée chelem en colère c'est je
suis très furieux je peux vous le dire
quoi parce que les gens qui voient ça ce
sont les gens qui plus tard vont voter
populiste vont bien c'est on n'a aucun
passe-droit on est au top on fait partie
du peuple ont essayé le résultat des
mouvements sociaux vous avez aujourd'hui
parce que les gens en ont marre qu une
certaine caste de gens profitent de tous
dans tous les domaines et ce n'est pas
que financier
c'est à dire je connais tel personne qui
va me faire passer et sa légende en
taule que je lui posais une saison
intéressante et je fais déjà souvent
d'un thé pnp et des gens non le noter ça
c'est ok ces gens que vous connaissez
des gens dont vous parlez sont choqués
mais oui sochaux
oui certes restée titia c'est votre
esthéticienne là donc c'est un dermato
non la question que vous posez c'est est
ce que ces gens qui nous regardent sont
choqués parce que ça se fait ou ils sont
choqués parce qu'ils peuvent pas le
faire répond la mairie personne qui nous
regardent qui demain serait millionnaire
est-ce que très franchement être à l
armée posez vous les bonnes questions
chez non parce que j'ai demandé alors à
l'udc
non parce que dans cette histoire là où
je ne suis pas choqué justement c'est
que ces deux stars donc céder 10,6 of
man et login du coup elles ont fait des
chèques restera comme aux états unis
tout le monde fait ça tous les gens
riches payent la fac à leurs rôles et
leurs enfants et toi même le sait que ça
se fait on voit dans les films
alors tout le monde la veut voir
l'examen au fond elle du coup bassins
sont quoi sont les deux bouc émissaire
de cette affaire et passent pour des
espèces de grosses mafieuses et c'est
alors qu'elle participe d'un système qui
est très est établie aux états unis où
tu paies d'al hilal
mon père est très riche qui construit à
18 sec et puis on prend mon fils à la
voix si bien sûr il faut avoir les
vacances ça
les sites américains dont un niveau très
très haut ils sont bien mes côtés
l'examen pas tous en même temps mais on
sait bien que ça a toujours marché comme
ça je dis pas que c'est pas bien mais
enfin que ça partait d'un bon à choquer
je pense que ça partait d'un bon
sentiment sont des mamans le meilleur
fonds deux enfants et donc voilà c'est
juste c'est juste ça je pense pas que ça
soit négatif après par contre me mets à
la place des autres élèves qui n'ont pas
accès voilà à ces universités et là elle
devrait apprendre à leurs enfants le
niveau zéro si rachel c'est que ça part
d'un bon sentiment parce que c'est ton
enfant mais forcément qu'elle met des
places limitées à 1 tu payes pour ton
enfant qui avait pas cette classe là et
tu prends la place d'un an prochain
vous savez quoi je vais beaucoup plus
dur dans la question est-ce que vous
l'auriez fait si vous avez été très
riche et que vous deux filles n'avaient
pas le niveau pour une grande entreprise
pour une grande nuit là dessus parce que
je leur ai fait mais c'est raisonner
catherine est ce que vous l'auriez fait
je pense que oui j'aurais fait aussi je
pense que les enfants les parents pour
leurs enfants ils sont prêts à tuer
assez singulier vous l'auriez fait très
bien vous l'auriez fait non parce que
c'est un mauvais signal que j'honore à
donner à mes enfants et je veux leur
inculquer un peu de valeur daniel donc
dû daniela mois elle va parler sinon
c'est exactement ce que j'ai dit c'est
on vous rendez compte alors faire faire
les meilleures études
ok mais alors on les mettra une place
qui aura la canule est pas la leur on
est con on ne signale cc du grand prix
bien sûr si on devait enlever les gens
qui ne sont pas à leur place pensez vous
vraiment que tout le monde très dans
l'émission par exemple
stark abusez pas droit choquée rafina
là-dessus tout ce que je voulais vous
dire et je dis aux gens et c'est très
sincèrement évidemment qu'on ait choqué
les clans choqué de voir des gens qui
font des choses qu'on peut pas faire
mais posez vous la question très
intelligemment c'est tout le côté aussi
un petit peu quand on est jeune et qu'on
n'a pas d'argent on est de gauche c'est
plutôt un coup quand on commence à
gagner trois tomes d'une droite recensés
pardon c'est très fréquent venais juste
aux gens posez vous la question si vous
aviez un enfant et beaucoup d'argent est
ce que vous le feriez je ne dis pas que
c'est bien ou pas réfléchissez vous vous
avez quatre heures heureusement rien
d'un conte des valeurs encore
heureusement